[Music]
researchers in california have come up
with a way to move water through a
structure filled with holes
without it leaking
the new idea uses the power of surface
tension and tiny 3d printing
called micro architecture to expose a
huge surface area of liquid to the
surrounding air
and these kinds of designs could have a
huge range
of different applications
liquids and gases are by definition
difficult to mold or structure
they need to be enclosed so they don't
leak everywhere
but this means it's usually quite hard
to get a lot of their surface area
into contact with their surroundings and
that puts a limit on how much surface
area
you can use for important functions like
absorbing carbon dioxide
or releasing heat the researchers at the
lawrence livermore national laboratory
looked at examples in nature which use
these kinds of processes
such as gas exchange in the lungs or the
movement of water through trees
trees use capillary action to draw water
up from the roots in tiny tubes
a process that depends on the way water
molecules stick to themselves
and their surroundings due to surface
tension it was this process which the
scientists wanted to harness
but to do so without enclosing the
liquid
seemed impossible so the team turned to
the world
of micro architecture they used one of
the world's most advanced
custom-built 3d printers to print tiny
cubic cells of only one millimeter wide
these tiny cubes are small enough to
hold water without
breaking its surface tension so the
sides of the cube can be completely
open without the water spilling out
meaning the surface area
exposed to the air outside is much
bigger
and by stacking hundreds of these tiny
cubes together
they created a scaffolding that liquids
can climb up
without being enclosed this process
only works at exceptionally small scales
that were previously impossible to
create
experiments showed the absorption of
gases by the liquid in these open
lattice structures
was up to three times faster than the
absorption of gases by the same volume
of liquid in an enclosed column
and by creating a network of these
open-faced cubes and tunnels
scientists think they'll even be able to
direct the flow of liquids through a
system
the applications of this are immense
from heating and cooling
energy-intensive systems like computer
servers
to transporting waste carbon dioxide in
industrial reactors
and returning it as a raw material to be
reused
and in space where controlling liquids
is even more problematic
the ability to have contained yet
open-faced liquid structures
could be groundbreaking for gas and heat
exchange in fact
without the limitations of gravity on
capillary action
directing liquids through these
microstructures could be extremely
efficient
this use of micro architecture creates
systems that are more organized than the
chaotic natural networks in trees or
lungs
and one day the scientists hope to
combine their models with
real living systems as they achieved
with these seeds
absorbing water through a printed
structure
creating hybrid biological organisms
with more efficient and more
organized features could have numerous
applications
in space agriculture tissue growth such
as semi-artificial lungs
and atmospheric cooling a pretty big
future
for these tiny liquid cubes
you